[音楽]
4日
おっん
[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
日本の大学の中で授業中炊飯器でお米を炊いても先生から怒られなかったっていう大学
があるのをご存知ですか
しっとりとどれ位いらっしゃいますよねあっにちょこちょこをいらっしゃいますけれど
も
はいここ慶應 sfc です
僕は授業中に炊飯器でお米を耐えて
まあ隣の席だったんですけどめちゃくちゃネット上で炎上させたことがあります
髪の毛をこんな感じでばっかり止めてまあ炎上部屋ですよね
それで学校に毎日通っていたこともありますしたニワトリ小屋を自分たちで竹を切って
作ってそこで10匹ぐらい
鶏を飼っていたこともあります
ふんどし一丁で新宿の街を適当に歩いて和みとが当たって食べれそうなものを食べ
るっていう事もしたことありますし
フィリピンのすらぐらいに入ってダンスのパフォーマンスをしてめちゃくちゃ人を集め
たこともあります
僕は大学時代に面白そうって思ったことに関しては何でもやってきたんですね
今日はこのいろいろやってみる秘訣というものについてお話ししようかなと思ってい
ます
そもそも僕は小さい時からいろんなことに挑戦できてたかっていうと全然違うんですね
むしろ僕は苦手な方でした
そんな僕を変えたきっかけあります
それが何かというと
浪人なんですね
僕はこの浪人をするまですごく受け身的にやることが多かったんです
親から勉強しろって言われたから勉強させられていたり習い事をやれって言われたから
習い事をやらされていたり中でもやっぱりやらされていた勉強っていうのはすごく
大嫌いになっちゃいました
中学校ぐらいまでは僕も真面目に勉強させられていたんですけれども
高校ぐらいに貼っ入ってからもう一気に反動がきちゃって行って勉強しなくなっちゃっ
たんですね
なので僕の高校3年生の12月
ところ大事な時期の全国猛暑の全国偏差値20代とかとってしまって僕はもう行きたい
だ
約1歳行けず滑り止めの大学一つにしか受からないっていうまあボロボロなぁ結果だっ
たんですね
親からそこの滑り止めに行くものだろうと思われたんですけれども
僕の場合は違いました
僕は3年間高校ラグビーをやっていてラグビー部って終わるの遅いんですね高校3年生
の11月10日なんですよ
そこから数ヶ月間くらいししかまともに勉強してないのにそこでいけるような大学に
行ったところで果たして自分ってかっこいいのかどうかってちょっと悩んでしまって親
に勉強させていく
れか飲んでまあもちろん怒られるんですよねだったらなんでもまあ滑り止め受けたんだ
って言われて
音しかに入ってなったんですけどまあいろいろケンカしてめちゃくちゃ喧嘩して最終的
に僕にとってやっと手に入れたろーにんだったんですよそうなってからすごい面白い
ことが起きるようになったんですね
それが何かというと
勉強が楽しいって感じるようになったんですよ
あんなに大嫌いだったはずの勉強がなんでこんなに楽しくなったんだろう
すごい考えたんですけれどもやっぱり自分で本気で勉強したいって思って勉強に
取り組んだからこそ楽しいって感じるようになったんだと思います
楽しいって感じるからこそ続くし実際に結果が出るし
この時に自分で積極的にやろうと思ったことはやってやろうと決めたわけですよね
て言っても実感するタイミングが悪かったんですよ
ここにも書いてある通り浪人したんですね
僕はまあ浪人2って一番やらないといけない事って勉強じゃないですか
何かやりたいことがパッと思い浮かんだとしてもそれを全部ハト回しにして勉強勉強
勉強みたいな感じで
何かやりたいことをどんどん後回しに後回し
していくとどうなるかというとそのやりたいことのやりたいドアいっていうのは
どんどん低くなっていくんですね
で最終的にそのやりたいことっていうのはなくなっちゃうんですよ
果たして何やりたかったんだけどわかんなくなっちゃったり忘れちゃったりするんです
よ
そういうことに僕はふと気づいてすごくもったいないって感じになったんですね
やりたいことがあったはずなのにそれがなくなっちゃうって現状がどうやったらこう
いうのはなくならないんだろうっていろいろ考えて勉強することとそのやりたいことは
消えないようにって言うその両立をするにはどうしたらいいんだろう
そう考えて僕は受験終わったらやってやろうっていうリストを作り始めたんですね
いわゆるやりたいって思ったことはとりあえずメモしようっていうことで始めたんです
よ
たとえば脳科学の本とかを読んであ脳みそってこんなに面白いんだ
ちょっと脳科学研究してみようって書いてんだったりとか
資料系の動物の解体とかでめちゃくちゃ炎上しているブログを読んで動物の書いてって
どんな行為なんだろちょっとやってみたいなって考えて変えたり立ったりとか
line のスタンプとかって個人で作れる
し言っても聞いて作ってみたいって書いたりとか
なあ受験終わったらリストってことで作り始めてたんですけれども
line のスタンプとか浪人中でも作れるんじゃないかなぁと思って一晩徹夜して
作ったりもしたんですけれどもこのやりたいことのメモというものがいろいろやって
みる上で大事な秘訣になるんじゃないかなというふうに僕は思っています
このやりたいことのメモというものには僕は2つの良い点があるんじゃないかなって
思ってます
一つが
成功体験を増やすことができるということです
どんなに小さいことでも何かしらメモをしてそれについてこなしてみるって言うことを
すると何かしら達成感というものを感じることができるんですね
どんなに小さいことでも大丈夫です例えばこのてデックスの前にちょっとひげを整えて
みるって話であったりとか朝は9時までに起きるって話で行ってるとか
宮木を忘れずにまあねるって言うような話であったりとか
普段何気なくなんとなーくやっていた秒な行動でもメモをするという行為を挟むことに
よってそれを成功体験に変えることができるんですね
そうすることで自分の自己肯定感が高まったりまた次のやりたいことのメモというもの
につながると思うのでこういう意味でメモは大事だと思っています
二つ目に
価値観を広げることができるという点ですねやりたいって思ったものに対して
それを放置せずにメモしてみるそんな生活を続けているとちょっとした違和感であっ
たりちょっとした自分のやりたいっていう気持ちに対してすごく敏感になるんですね
で実際にそのことに関してメモしてやってみるということをすると普段見過ごしてた
ような知識だったり体験っていうものを得ることができるので
知らなかったような価値観というものを広げることができます
成功体験を増やすことができる価値観を広げることができる
やりたいことのメモには後ような良い点があるんじゃないかなと思っています
僕は何を使ってメモしてたかっていうと自分の携帯を使っても知らないんですね
これ僕のホーム画面なんですけれどもこの中の
まあこのメモのアプリ2つを使ってメモしてました
こっちの左のほうのメモのアプリこれそもそも iphone に入っている名もなん
ですけれども
声だけでメモができるっていうのは良い点があるんですね例えば
お腹すいたってメモして
青みたいな感じお腹すいになっちゃったんですけれどもこういう感じでメモしてくれる
んですよ
なので例えば自転車こいでる時とか2パットアイディア思い浮かんだときに声だけで
パッとメモしたりとか
夜寝る時とかにちょっと文字打つのダルいけどアイデア思い浮かんでしまったってとき
に声だけでメモができたりとか
雨降ってる時に文字
打てないって時でもこういうだけでメモすることができます
こっちの evernote っていう緑のメモのアプリの方は自分の携帯だけじゃ
なくて友達の携帯であったり友達のパソコンであったりいろんな機器においてメモする
ことができる
というような良い点があります
ばこういうような2つのメモ使い分けながら僕はたくさんのメモというものをしてき
ました
どれぐらいメモしてるんだろうってちょっと気になって今回
計算してみたんですけれども1年間の約1000ぐらいのメモをしているというような
計算になりました
受験終わったらリストっていうことで書いてた時は1日に1回ぐらいの目もあったん
ですけれども
大学入ってから僕は5回ぐらいの女も1日にするようになりました
なので僕は今この形態に自分のやりたい事っていうのが4000ぐらい入っているん
ですね
そういうようなメモのおかげで僕はいろんなことに挑戦できたと思っているんですね
で実際にどんな感じのメモをしてたかって皆さんちょっと気になると思うんですけれど
も
こんな感じのメモをしてました2016年じゃない18年って用意したんですけれども
まあすごいどうでもいいようなくだらない女もいっぱい書いてますね
靴下を買うとか方位磁石買うとかリュックをスリムにするとかピクルスを食べるとか
ザリガニパーティーとかぼく何言ってんだろうっていう感じ
よくわからないようなことも書いてるんですねちょっとしたパッと思いついた
タイミングでとりあえずメモしてみるって言うことができている証拠なんですけれども
まあこういうようなメモが実際に面白い
いうものにつながった例としてはこんなものがあります
2つ用意したんですけれども星マークに囲まれた夏休みってやつとこっての2016年
9月のメモなんですけれども僕星マーク
何かっていうと重要なあって思ったりとか見返したいって思ったものにはつけるように
してるんですねでメモには検索機能があるのでほしい
マークをパップ計算した時に重要なって思ったものだけやでていけるっていうような
マーク風になってるんですけれどもってまぁ余談でした
このまあ夏奴にやりたいことってことなんですけれども寝袋ちょっと買ってみたいと
フリーハグやってみたいとか
7役やってみたいといろいろ書いてますけれども実際にここに書いてあることを実現さ
せました
盗撮動物の解体についてはこの1ヵ月後にやりましたし
予備自衛官補っていう自衛隊のある1種にもなりましたし
脳科学の研究室も実際に所属してやってみるということをしました
ピタの方も実際に10月ににアトリ譲り受けましたし
動物の解体ワークショップというのも実際にやりました
こんな感じで自分がやりたいと思ってタイミングでとりあえずメモして
でそれについてやっているやっていくっていう中で僕は成功体験を増やしていって
いろんなことに対して挑戦をして言って色々と価値観というものを広げることができた
んですね
その中でも
僕はあることに対して価値観が一気に変わってしまった出来事があったんですね
それが何かというと
動物の解体なんですよ
まあさっきもちょこっと書いてあったんですけれども僕は2015年大学1年生の8月
に自分でカモを殺しました
彼もぐっと抑えて首を捻って亀裂なって
で切れ味のいいな訳で首を切って殺して知恵を出して
焼き鳥にして食べるというような経験をしました
僕はこの日から一切ため残しっていうのはできなくなっちゃったんですね
何か食べるってこういうことなんだってすごく実感したし食べ物が今まで見てた価値観
では見れなくなってしまって
動物の命のように感じるようになってしまったんですね
それから僕はめちゃくちゃためのこすってのムカつくんやったんですね
食べ残しって何なんだろうといろいろ調べて日本には食料廃棄問題っていう問題が深刻
化しているっていうようなことを知りました
でどうやったらそういうもんだ言って解決できるんだろうと色々勉強して発進不良に
なったんですね
友達とかが食べ残ししているを見ると多いこれって動物の命だったんだぞとか言い始め
たりとか
なんかこれ1年間600万と日本には食べ残しって終わってなーとか色々言い始めたん
ですけど入ったところで何も変わらないし言われた本人からしたらなんだこいつって
なるだけなんですよでどういったらこういう人たちが実際に食べ残しをしなくなるん
だろうっていろいろ考えたんですけどもじゃあ自分と同じように
動物が食べ物になる過程っていうものを見てもらえば
ため残しって減るんじゃないかなんか食べ物についての裏側だったり背景っていうもの
について考えてくれる人が増えて食を大切にしてくれる人が増えるんじゃないか
そういうような思いから僕は狩猟を勉強し始めたんですね
で実際に僕は狩猟免許を取得して漁師になって動物の解体ワークショップというものを
開くようになりました
また狩猟って実は冬しかやっちゃいけないって法律を決められてるんですよね
なのでそれ以外も解体ワークショップシュタイナーということであっじゃあ家畜を
買おう
でもって僕は200鳥のチークっていうものも始めるようになったんですね
そしてもったいないとって言われる配置になってしまいそうな食べ物を持ち寄った料理
界というものも始めるようになりました
大学生の皆さんはご存じの通り
なんか大学生ってめちゃくちゃための星が多いんですね
なんか親からすげー食いきれないぐらいの仕送りがたなーって送られてきたんだったり
とか
なんかちょっと料理めんどくさいなぁと思って外食ラって言っちゃったりとかそういう
ことによって冷蔵庫の中にめちゃくちゃ種だってしまう食べ物がいっぱいあるんですね
まぁそういうたボールになってしまいそうなものをみんなで持ち寄ってもらってそれで
な料理して食べてみるという機会を月に1回ぐらい
開けばための子知ってるんじゃないかそんな思いで僕はこういうような会を開くように
なりました
こんな感じで僕は食料廃棄問題という僕にとってすごくビビッと来て本気で取り組み
たいっていうも思えるものに見つけて今取り組んでるんですけれどもこういうものを
見つけることができたのって実はメモのおかげなんですね
で実際にメモのおかげでこういったことに取り組むことができました
やりたいことのメモというものをしていると自分の中でビビっとくるものを見つける
ことができるはずです
食料廃棄問題に向けて今どんなことをやっていこうっていろいろメモしてそれをこなし
ていくっていう家庭なんですけれどもそれがすごい楽しいですし
今後僕はいろんな挑戦をしていこうと思っています皆さんもちょっとした違和感であっ
たりちょっとした自分の中にやりたいって気持ちが生まれたときにそれを放置するん
じゃなくて
耳を傾けてみてください
実際にそれを言語化してメモしてみてください
どんどんどんどん実現去っていって成功体験を増やしていってビビっとくるものを
見つけてみてください
そうすれば人生楽しくなるはずだし自分に自信をつけることができると思っています
やりたいことのメモというものをしていると普段
に市場だと思ってたものだったり当たり前だと思ってたものを変えることができると
思っています皆さんも是非やりたいことのメモというものを試してみてくださいという
メモ
今お手持ちのスマートフォンそういう資料やつのでよろしくお願いしますということで
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]